bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france une réunion qui est
donc organisée ce jeudi entre la ville
de paris et les assureurs sur
l'indemnisation des victimes mais sans
les principaux intéressés des victimes
elles mêmes
comment vous l'expliquez honnêtement
aucune explication par rapport à 7
cette absence d'invitation nous n'avons
pas été conviés 29 mois que nous faisons
le point tous les mois nous sommes
invités pour faire le point tout le
monde a connaissance de la situation des
victimes de l'explosion
malheureusement il n'y a aucune action
si ce n'est oui on est convié pour faire
le point mais pour une réunion
stratégique comme celle de demain qui se
tient au ministère de la justice nous
n'avons pas été conviée non nous n'avons
pas reçu de réponse de la diam nous
n'avons pas reçu de réponse de la mairie
de paris concernant cette absence
d'invitation enfin d'intégration à cette
réunion vous êtes quand même je me
répète un les principaux intéressés qui
va vous représenter à cette réunion et
défendre vos intérêts de personne y a
pas d'avocats il ya personne non c'est
une réunion qui a été organisée par
l'adiaf à la demande du premier ministre
le premier ministre parfum lorsqu'il a
envoyé un courrier à 10
nous a confirmé que une réunion se
tiendrait à la diable que derrière les
associations seraient conviés sauf que
là il en est autrement la dia va
organiser cette réunion
grdf pardon grdf général y sera présent
la ffa aussi
la mairie de paris aussi et les
associations ne sont pas conviés ni les
avocats aujourd'hui mais d'avant quelle
est votre situation à vous mais aussi
aux autres victimes on imagine que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont tout perdu en
tout cas matériellement parlant mais on
imagine le traumatisme que ça doit être
de perdre voilà son appartement son
l'immeuble entier alors pour en effet
pour les riverains c'est une situation
catastrophique pour les victimes
blessées
devenue handicapée c'est une situation
dramatique
aujourd'hui des personnes se bat pour
retrouver pour retrouver au moins
enfin les un état de santé si je veux
dire pour pour la possibilité de se
mettre debout
je prends le cas des quatre grièvement
blessé à mort à mme roche
inès angela inès est actuellement au
bloc pour vous dire fin est actuellement
boc est actuellement hospitalisé
donc toujours pour les blessures suite
suite à l'explosion elle a perdu l usage
de ses jambes
angela pareil a perdu l usage de sa
jambe à mort a été grièvement blessée
devenue handicapée a perdu l'usagé de
son oeil de son bras gauche et de sa
main et à mme roche a été éventrée plus
une opération niveau de l'oso fage donc
des opérations très très lourde des
séquelles très l'autre et j'ai aussi
bien sûr une pensée pour luis miguel qui
a perdu son épouse laura qui est décédé
qui est décédé le 12 janvier à aux trois
orphelins notamment à l'aîné qui bien
sûr sa mère lui manque lui manque
beaucoup il ya un manque donc toutes ces
personnes
et toutes les autres victimes bien sûr
blessés les touristes présents
toutes ces personnes n'ont pas été
reconnues victimes aujourd'hui elle se
bat au quotidien soit pour retrouver un
minimum de de santé physique entre
guillemets même si elles ne retrouveront
jamais l'usagé des mains des fins des
légendes du bras pour pour amant mais
mais il n'y a pas de reconnaissance
aujourd'hui aucune reconnaissance
donc elle se bat on se bat et ce mépris
ne fait 4 pardonnez moi madame aucune
reconnaissance met donc aucune
indemnisation pour le moment deux ans et
demi après à aucune indemnisation il n'y
a pas on n'a même pas de reconnaissance
en tant que victime
enfin ce qui ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'on a un assureur s'est positionné dès
le 12 janvier qui est l'assureur
generali qui est l'assureur de
l'immeuble du 6 rue de trévise
aujourd'hui il est seul donc forcément
tout est enfin là moindres provisions si
je veux si on peut appeler ça une
provision c'est plus une avance de frais
les victimes justifiée par des devis des
devis pour obtenir des soins parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout ce qui est chirurgie
et c'est réparatrice puisque c'est des
opérations très lourde de mieux
forcément à des devis de l'ap-hp des
services hospitaliers hospitalier oui et
il faut une prise en charge et général
ina de ne versent des provisions que sur
par le biais de deux vies aujourd'hui
vous vous envisager une action en
justice si aucun accord d'indemnisation
n'est trouvée notamment demain pour vous
irez clairement en justice de demander
des comptes
alors on ira en truites car nous nous
sommes enfin les victimes sont
françaises elles sont européennes
on a des touristes qui étaient présents
le 12 janvier qu'ils ont et qu'ils sont
victimes aussi nous nous saisit enfin
oui il y aura la saisine de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme où et
comment est-ce que nous avons interpellé
l'état nous avons à faire a interpellé
le président de la république nous avons
interpellé la mairie de paris
personne ne peut rien pour les victimes
présentent le 12 janvier 2009 19
donc nous n'avons pas d'autre choix si
on passe aux orphelins si on passe on
pense aux autres en vous handicapez on
pense aux riverains
on ne peut pas laisser aujourd'hui
les victimes dans cette situation
clairement pour vous aujourd'hui à un
responsable identifié à vos yeux
dans ce drame j'ai envie de dire
l'instruction suit son cours maintenant
la mairie a été mise en examen
sur ce dossier donc forcément la mairie
doit être à un moment enfin on a besoin
d'acteurs on a besoin de gens autour
d'eux qu'ils se mettent autour d'une
table et qui pense aux victimes au drame
et non pas aux et non pas au parti parce
que là aujourd'hui c'est un problème
quand on est on est honnêtement ballotté
entre entre les politiques
enfin c'est vraiment le cas c'est une
affaire politique
merci beaucoup madame les victimes n'ont
rien à faire dans une affaire politique
évidemment merci beaucoup aux linda
howard avoir été avec nous en direct sur
arte france pour merci à vous pour ce
témoignage et bon courage